so we've sent we being the bite
Administration we have sent billions to
Ukraine to protect their borders even as
we have opened our own to the world
why are we doing this exactly well as
Joe Biden has told us repeatedly doing
as Winston Churchill invitation we're
doing it to protect democracy but of
course the irony here is
Ukraine is not a democracy in any
recognizable sense Ukrainian government
has banned media Outlets that are
hostile to it they've also shut down
opposition parties they arrested the
main opposition there that's a democracy
so because we allowed that to happen in
fact we funded it all now the Ukrainian
government has decided that they can
impose censorship in our country the
Ukrainian government has issued a black
list of so-called Russian propagandists
Americans
that list includes Rand Paul Senator
Rand Paul of Kentucky Tulsi gabbard
who's serving in the U.S military and
Glenn Greenwald among many others so we
thought we'd speak to a couple of them
starting off tonight Glenn Greenwald
he's an independent journalist his work
is on sub stack among other places Glenn
thanks so much for coming on so you're
you're being blacklisted by the
Ukrainian government which is a beacon
of democracy tell us how this works
yeah I mean I thought president
zielinski had a war to run apparently he
has a lot of time to watch The Morning
Joe show on MSNBC where they sit around
for hours accusing everybody they want
to discredit of being a Kremlin agent
and teaching American liberals how to do
the same you know it's easy to mop but
it's actually quite outrageous Tucker
the ukrainians have a conflict with this
neighboring country in Russia they're
totally free to pursue whatever War
policies they want they can fight Russia
for the next 10 years if they choose but
that's not what they're doing they're
begging and in a sense demanding that
other countries including my own the
United States provide them with a
seemingly endless supply of weapons and
money which means we not only have the
right but the obligation to debate that
and ask whether that's in the interest
of the American people to do and so for
zelenski to essentially try and Export
the repression he's imposed in his own
country here to the United States by
shutting down debate and accusing those
of us asking questions of being Kremlin
agents or Russian propagandas is takes
incredible all while he's also demanding
that we turn over all our money and
weapons to him at the same time
this is the guy George W bush described
as the George Washington of our age I
haven't heard really anybody in
Washington say a single word about this
yeah I mean you know from the beginning
as you know as as well as anybody Tucker
there was a very concerted effort to
eliminate all space to ask any questions
anyone who asked the question of whether
we should do more to prevent the word
diplomatically like Tulsa gabbard or
whether we should risk our own money and
our in a potential nuclear exchange with
Russia over Ukrainian border disputes
got called a Kremlin agent or a Russian
asset and this is the strategy that
they're using to try and prevent Us in
the United States from exercising our
freedom to debate what role our
government should play in that war
exactly in the name of democracy they
shut it down Glenn Greenwell thank you
so much for that
thanks Tucker
so Tulsi gabbard is also on this
Blacklist she's also some of the
Ukrainian government says should be
censored she serves in the US military
she served in the United States Congress
she ran for president now she's joining
us and we're happy that she is
Congressman thank you so much for coming
on what's your reaction to finding
yourself on this Blacklist
I see the hypocrisy Tucker the hypocrisy
of this Blacklist is and frankly why the
American people should care about this
is the Biden Harris Administration and
the Washington Elite from both parties
are continuing to be willing to
impoverish the American people and
people around the world and push us
closer and closer to nuclear war and
Holocaust all to protect democracy and
defeat autocracy in Ukraine and all of
this is happening as the Ukrainian
president is frankly exposing that there
is no democracy in Ukraine you mentioned
a few examples of some of the things
that he's doing in silencing any
dissenting voices imprisoning political
opponents banning all political activity
from the 11 opposition parties uh
frankly taking control of all national
media under his unified information
policy and now he's turning his sights
on Americans not only myself and others
you've mentioned but a sitting U.S
senator the danger of this again goes to
the cost that our leaders are willing to
exact as they continue this facade of a
push for so-called democracy and defeat
autocracy the whole thing is so
hypocritical and we need to hold our
leaders accountable for it I couldn't
agree more I have to ask you since you
served in Washington uh for years I know
you're not generally aligned with Steve
Banner at least in the public mind but
you watched him get convicted last week
of contempt of congress for not
cooperating with the January 6th
committee while many others Eric Holder
Lois Lerner have not been put on trial
for ignoring subpoenas from the Congress
what's your reaction to this
it shows the double standard in
Washington but more dangerously it shows
how this Administration is so willingly
weaponizing our department of justice to
act as their own personal political hit
squad and going after political
opponents and turning a blind eye to
people on their own team
this is incredibly dangerous because
when you look at what's at the heart of
our democracy it is the rule of law it
is our ability As Americans to be able
to trust that these public institutions
are serving the public interest and not
favoring whoever's in power versus who's
not in power that no matter our
political affiliation how we use our
Free Speech the color of our skin how we
worship none of these things should
matter because we should have faith that
our justice system will treat us equally
and fairly across the board this
weaponization of the Department of
Justice is incredibly dangerous and sets
a dangerous precedent that that
undermines this very Foundation of our
democracy
you served in the Congress as a Democrat
when the Washington Post started
attacking you I started paying very
close attention to what you were saying
why why did Slackers because you're a
person in principle that's why and they
hate that I appreciate you coming on
tonight Chelsea gabbard as always thank
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight